hey welcome to a new project camp update
in this video we're going to show you
some sensors we've installed on the land
including this wind meter
and also going to talk more about all
the electronics how we hooked everything
up together
and we're going to show you a map
because we're currently mapping out all
the native trees on the land to think
about the future of our landscape
so get ready for some geeky stuff
[Music]
hello guys hello who are you
uh i'm naomi ilding i'm jenna
i'm gonna be here for two months i'm
from the netherlands um i'm gonna be
logging native trees in the area
we're now up the rock that base camp is
down there
i think it would be great to show all
the native trees in the area
in
contrast to all the mimosa and the
eucalyptus
and in the future they might want to
build stuff and i recommend or like
everybody recommends not to
build next to native trees because you
might need to chop them you want to
regenerate the whole land i just picked
a waypoint app
so i'm going to be standing next to a
tree wait until the gps locates locate
me
and then create a waypoint add some
information like the name the height of
the tree gave it a color code
and then walk to the next one
and we have ziggy here for support right
mental support
just eating the treats
yeah we tried the teaching to eat the
eucalyptus and the mimosa
we just like sticks a lot do you think
that will solve the problem of project
camp with the mimosas we might need a
lot of dogs just
all right let's do it cool
this is the app
the blue spot shows where we are
this green area is base camp
here we have the old ruins
we just walked up here
i'll show you the logs i did now work
from base camp this is all mimosa forest
and then the first native tree i saw i
started
and just like locked everything i saw
the different color codes like the red
ones or the strawberry trees the green
ones are the oak trees
english oak
pink is
cork tree
which we really love here and the pine
trees are the black ones
and it's fun to see that the whole line
this this is already like the border of
our land but this one is all like
planted eucalyptus trees
um so i just worked my way up to the big
rock um and this was my first area
the app is called
traglia
so next to the traclia app for the
waypoints i use plantnet
it's an identifying app
you can download it for free
put your location in
so i'm we're in europe now
and you can add photos from your gallery
or even like take them new you add a
picture
like from a leaf you can add like it's a
leaf or fruit bark or flower and it
helps identify this specific species
and what are strawberry trees star wars
cheese are for bush-like trees
we can walk up in a bit uh there's
different branches and the little fruits
are like spiky strawberry like fruits
and i think the name is just like
because the the fruit turns red it looks
like a strawberry but you can't eat them
right i'm actually not sure you can you
can you can that's fun they stick it to
your teeth no we should try them if
they're better than strawberries
themselves you can make it tasty
i haven't tried we'll definitely try now
let's go let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
and these are the little fruits ah i
think i have seen them already
they're turning already they're turning
red already
strawberry tree
and this is amazing for wood carving if
you want to make a spoon or something
and it should have a lot of cannon yeah
did you bite on it
it doesn't even look like a strawberry
it doesn't does it
sorry if that's on camera please don't
put it in
ziggy what tree is that
it's a is
[Music]
what do we have there
it's an oak it's an english oak
um you can see that the light green
short stalks
[Music]
earlobes at the beginning of the stock
the most common one in the land here
oakwise
quite easy to recognize this one
this is a cork tree
so this is the burned mother tree
and behind it it has new growth so we
will lock this
i will stand next to it as close as i
can
get the gps going again
make a waypoint
put down
[Music]
cork tree
a cork oak sorry
and then it's
logged
[Music]
right
there
are there many cocktails here left
yeah actually i would say quite quite a
lot um like a few big ones
you can actually see the
the bark is being burned or has been
burned
but around it all new ones sprout
i wouldn't say it is
the
most
for coming tree here
but um yeah they could they could come
back
i'm quite optimistic about these
right let's go to the next one yes
there's a pine there's a pine
uh quite a tall one i would say
i go in again as
close as i can make a waypoint
i chose the color black for this icon
and saving it
there you have it bueno
[Music]
what is this this is pyrenees oak so
you can differentiate between the
english oak and the pyrenees by looking
at the leaves
this is quite velvety almost like hairy
and especially on the back it feels very
soft
and the color is a bit more a grayish
green
and that is one of the characteristics
of the pyrenees oak
we're here at english oak and this these
are called plant gals
they're actually like abnormal growths
in the oak
they're caused by various parasites such
as fungus fungi or bacteria
mites or even wasps
they're actually now empty they start
out really green and they dry out a very
papery feeling
and they're quite
common and oaks
[Music]
so yeah this is the terracotta pot i
just found these can be found all up in
the mimosa forest and like of the big
rock
they're all broken but they used to used
to have them for gathering all the resin
from the mimosa
so if you cut them in mozart bark it's
slowly like poured out resin like the
hearts
it's actually quite nice we find them
and we take them back to the camp and we
use them for like slow watering and put
them next to plants and stuff so we try
to gather as much as we can and they are
burned right they burned yeah from the
forest from the last fire yeah 2018
17 yeah so most of them are burnt when
we find them
[Music]
so this is what you do
yeah so knowing that the path we just
walked is the border of the land
and down there is the road
so i just need to get like zigzag
through every meter of the mimosa forest
and
knowing that mimosa represses other
species growth that we won't find any
other species just maybe some eucalyptus
sometimes some thorns like bremels
but just to be safe as a good ecologist
you need to get like every meter
so i'll just continue zig-zagging my way
through this area all right
[Music]
all right
that's it for today huh that is it for
today we did a square today um a
square's a hector this wasn't really a
dance area so we could get a lot done
today
um
yeah
i would say that the whole project area
is around a bit more than 10 hectares
i hope to get like all the logging of
the native trees done but it will be a
very
hard project to do some hectares are
very dense in native trees
the one we just just did this afternoon
or this morning
um wasn't really dense was like mostly
mimosa forest
so yeah it's gonna be a lot of work but
a lot of fun
hey i'm jerry i'm from the netherlands
and i've been here for a week to install
a home monitoring system
so
in the last season they've installed
like the solar panels and all of these
electronics and back then he already
mentioned that it's important to be able
to get some statistics out of this
because here at project com we want to
measure
different aspects of
off-grid living
and we want to see how the land grows
how it evolves
so to make a uniform platform for this
i installed a raspberry pi running home
assistance
and
that is really a big open source project
that is made for home automation
so to capture a lot of data sensor input
and based on that also control different
aspects
so with that we know how much energy we
use how much
solar power we are generating and how
much is still left in the battery for
example
but over time we can add more sensors
like a weather station which we will
show in a bit but also more
sensors like
water well sensor to see if we still
have enough water
and to keep all of this organized we
made a
display
inside of the kitchen container
where
we show if the battery is charging
how much ac power we are using
and how much is still left in the
battery
so
for that we mounted this display
where you can see that currently the
battery is at 63 percent
and it's in the green this arrow so that
means that the battery is now charging
and that's because the solar is
generating a lot of energy
so in the morning it was kind of cloudy
but now the weather is getting better so
we're generating more
electricity and we're basically not
consuming any ac power not a lot so it's
mainly just the fridge being on and some
tools being used on the ruin
the coolest thing here is that you see
that there is zero kilowatt hours from
the grid because we are basically just
fully off grid so we really rely on
solar energy and energy stored in the
battery
and with this system we can yeah
basically track a lot of different
said
different sensors and different setups
so we also implemented a weather station
where we can see how the ground
temperature is evolving
how much light is being uh
shined on different parts of the land
and also the
the soil so if the soil is very dry or
if it's very wet
uh lately it's been very dry because
basically
the last two weeks have been super hot
and no rain at all and over time we also
want to track different more manual
settings uh
manual yeah sensors as you wish
so for example the amount of people at
one time at project comp
uh the times that we've seen foxes
the amount of gas bottles that we still
use because this is the only
fossil fuel that we're still relying on
and also the amount of water that we
consume and that goes through the system
and goes back into the well
here we have a small sensor setup
so it's being powered by a small solar
panel and this generates all the
electricity that the sensor needs
and then once every 15 minutes it sends
it to the raspberry pi that i showed in
the back
and that really captures and logs all
the data
this is a small
yeah food container box that we thought
it would be useful to
use to keep it waterproof
and these are just very simple
microcontrollers
so we really want to create a platform
that different people can create
different sensors to measure different
aspects of the land
okay so that's everything about the
weather station here over time there
will be more sensors more statistics
but this is a nice first introduction
and
basically from here on we will keep you
up to date in the future
and for now enjoy the rest of the video
and see you
so one sensor we've installed before
jerry came with all these geeky sensors
is this
wind meter it measures the strength of
the wind and the main reason for
installing this was to check if it's
worth it to add a wind turbine to
generate electricity
so we actually already installed it last
year on the top of the highest point of
the land
but we realized whatever electricity we
generate there we're probably not going
to put a wind turbine there because we
need to pull the cable all the way to
base camp so since a few months we put
it here in base camp because it would be
way more realistic if we get electricity
to actually hook it up to our system
and it probably would be more of a small
wind turbine there was more wind up the
rock
but yeah harder to get electricity so
here would be a smaller
turbine with probably bigger blades but
a small motor so here you can see a
simulation of what a three meter blade
would look like and overall this project
is a research done by from waste to wind
and they're actually with fresh plastic
trying to make a wind turbine from
recycled plastic and using 3d printing
so you can find more about that research
here
but yeah overall it's an ongoing topic
and ideally also we hooked this one up
to our system that we all have digitally
and synced so it's easier to extract all
the data so this is still generation one
[Music]
hello today we are in sao joan inu
because daniel invited us
on his property to pick oranges
because he's working in the united
nations and he's not here to pick them
and they just wrote away so he sent us
an email and invited us and
we're gonna pick some fresh oranges
and there we have jadan
we have julie
and we have ted
and me of course felix
[Music]
so you have it a lot in portugal that
people have orange trees on their
property
and since the young people move away or
i don't know go for work in the big
cities oranges just get not picked
so a lot of places you have a lot of
orange trees with a lot of falling
oranges
fresh and nice to eat but no one picks
them
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey
[Music]
here we have all the picked oranges took
us maybe 10 minutes
quite a lot there are still some left in
the tree
but i guess that's kind of everything we
need for the moment
so
thank you daniel
for the oranges
of course we uh we use the oranges after
plucking them uh we made some uh some
orange juice
for breakfast and we made an orange cake
of course you can make many more things
with oranges and i think we're also
going to look into
preserving the oranges so for instance
drying them making a drying rack drying
the peels and drying maybe a little
orange in order to preserve them and
save as much oranges as we can from the
trees that are producing them but the
consumers that are not there anymore
all right so that was it for this video
and next video is number 58 so we're
going to talk about our current problems
or challenges and we're also going to do
a q a so if you guys have any question
for me the project the people here let
us know in the comments and then we can
talk about them next week
all right that was it for this video
thanks for watching if you already want
to see the next update make sure to
support on patreon if not no problem
we'll just see you again next week same
channel same time
bye
[Music]
hey there it's me again felix the video
maker who made the videos in the last
four months for this channel
i guess you know it already i'm gonna
stop with my work
if you want to know more about that
there is a little message in the youtube
project camp community section
anyway just wanted to say thank you guys
for your amazing support and the lovely
comments in the last videos
really made me happy to read that and if
you want you can have a look on my
instagram or my website
and yeah stay tuned new people gonna
come also new video maker so
i guess gonna be exciting
and
i'm yeah gonna go back soon to germany
so
i hope you enjoyed the show
and thank you again and
take care goodbye
[Music]
you